الدمار رغم زعم كييف تصديها
للصواريخ. يجيب الاوكران ان
انه اسقط تسعا وعشرين من اصل خمس
وثلاثين طائرة مسيرة وسبعة
الحرب تنتهي بعد. والمعارك سجال
بين الطرفين لتصرح هيئة الاركان
للاسلحة الغربية. في المقابل
اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانية اعتراض
واسقاط احد عشر صاروخا من نوع
اسكندر اطلقتها القوات الروسية
الملاجئ. تعلنها بعض وكالات
الانباء. نعم الدفاعات
لمنظومة صواريخ اس ثلاثمائة وست
نقاط تحكم لتشتعل الحرب اكثر
فاكثر مع كل هذه الهجمات يا
سادة. ومع اندلاع كل هذه المعارك
نتحرك قليلا نحو جيرانها. لتعلن
الحكومة البولندية ادراج
الدفاعية في مقاطعتي خرسون
وزبروجيا جنوبي البلاد. واضافت
ولكن هذه المرة الى اي
الهيئة ان القوات الاوكرانية شنت
خمس عشرة غارة جوية على مواقع
الى ان المدفعية استهدفت ثلاثة
مخازن للذخيرة اسلحة ومجمعا
اعلن المستشار السابق لرئيس
البنتاجون العقيد دوجلاس ماجيوغر
لمدة اسبوع من اي حرب قادمة قد
يتعرض لها الامريكان ذلك بسبب
الصراع مع روسيا في اوكرانيا.
واذا كان هذا هو حال اقوى دولة
هنا ادرك الغرب مخاطر استمرار
الحرب وها هم الغربيون يرمون
للايقاع به. نعم. هنا افادت
صحيفة لاري بوبليكا بان الدول
السبع تريد اقناع الزيلينسكي
بالسلام بسرعة. وتعد ضمانات
امنية لاوكرانيا وذلك في حال
تسوية ملف الازمة. من بين
في العالم فماذا نقول عن بقية
الدول الغربية هزولت ورب الكعبة.
انه لم يتبقى من الاسلحة
للولايات المتحدة سوى ما يكفي
الشمالية ترعب جيرانها واليابان
تعلن حالة الطوارئ. وجيش
والسعودية وامريكا ترفعان
رايتهما البيضاء امام القوى
غضبا وليرفع حدة هجماته قليلا ها
هو يدخل صواريخ سكود المرعبة على
خط الحرب الاوكرانية. لتتلقى
كييف حصة الاسد من غضب الدب
الاحتلال يقتحم المدن الفلسطينية
بهجوم هو الاعنف منذ سنوات.
الروسي. حيث اعلنت وزارة الدفاع
الروسية قصف مطارات في اوكرانيا
السودانية. القيصر الروسي يكشر
عن انيابه. قيصر موسكو يستشيط
وتدمير كل الاهداف العسكرية
المعادية هناك. بما في ذلك مراكز
زينسكي يتودد. بولندا تواصل
استثارة غضب الدب الروسي والغرب
يحضر طعما لالقائه ام فهل يتم
ابتلاع هذا الطعم؟ كوريا
الاوكرانية تخوض معارك مع
الصواريخ الروسية في سماء كييف
مختلفة بهجوم جوي واسع النطاق.
فيا لها من مجزرة استنزاف
الصواريخ وذلك حسب تصريحاتهم.
ولكن هنا السؤال ما كل هذا
مع الاشارة الى تمكن الدفاعات
الاوكرانية من صد العشرات من تلك
واشنطن اسلحتنا لم تعد تكفي سوى
لاسبوع واحد من الحرب وسماء كييف
الاوكرانية. ولقاء بوتين
ولوكاشينكو ينتهي بدخول الاخير
على العاصمة كييف. وكما نشاهد
هلع وخوف الشعب الاوكراني من هذه
الهجمات الشرسة لتدعو الحكومة
الاوكرانية السكان الى البقاء في
موسكو تحاول استنزاف الدفاعات
الجوية الاوكرانية عبر هجمات
مقرات اطلاق الطائرات المسيرة.
بينما اعلن سلاح الجو الاوكراني
الاوكرانية بان القوات الروسية
تواصل ما سمته بعملياتها
قيادة ومراكز رادار ومعدات طيران
ومرافق تخزين ومستودعات اسلحة
نتيجة طبيعية لعملكم المتفاني
كرئيس التركية والقادم معنا
طوكيو تأهب دفاعها لاعتقادها بان
صناعي عبارة عن صاروخ باليستي.
وصفت بانها الاعنف منذ سنوات
واعلنت المقاومة تصديها لاقتحام
والتعاون من اجل امن واستقرار
اوروبا. من جانبه اعلن الكرملين
الاحداث والتطورات. اعلنت
اليابان انها تلقت اخطارا من
القصيرة التي وقعت الاسبوع
الماضي. فيما اعلن وزير التنمية
كوريا الشمالية تبلغها فيه
اعتزامها اطلاق قمر صناعي في
تمركز القوات الروسية وعتادها
ومنظوماتها الصاروخية. واشارت
مقاتلات اف ستة عشر. واكد ان لدى
روسيا الوسائل اللازمة للرد على
اصابة خمسة عشر فلسطينيا
بالاختناق. قالت الوساطة
الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
لتكون الضمانات مجرد رماد على
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال مخيم عسكر
شرقي مدينة نابلس ما اسفر عن
الامريكية المسيرة للتفاوض بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
ستجرى في مدينة جدة السعودية
لتمديد الهدنة الانسانية في
السودان بمنطقة جدة السعودية ان
الطرفين لن يلتزما بالهدنة
الاجتماعية الاتحادية في السودان
احمد ادم بخيت ان مفاوضات جديدة
البلاد. بعد اسراب من المسيرات
بوتين يطلق وابلا من الصواريخ
صحية نقل على اثرها الى المستشفى
خلال زيارته موسكو ولقائه مع
ان بوتين وجه رسالة لاردوغان قال
فيها الفوز في الانتخابات كان
الاسابيع المقبلة بحسب متحدث في
خفر السواحل الياباني لتعلن
اقتحم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مدينة جنين وسط اشتباكات مسلحة
المدينة هناك اصيب ثمانية
فلسطينيين برصاص الاحتلال. كما
لافروف الدول الغربية من نيتها
تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين على
العيون الاوكرانية فقط. والغرب
يعلم ذلك وانتم تعلمون ذلك. ومن
ذلك. مضيفا ان روسيا تسعى مع
الدول الافريقية وكذلك دول
جزرة للزينسكي كالذي يريد ان
يستدرج ارنبا فيجعل الجزرة طعما
الضمانات السياسية منح كييف
الفرصة للشروع في مفاوضات
ضمانات الى الوعيد الروسي. حيث
حذر وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرجي
امريكا اللاتينية لاعتماد
العملات الوطنية وتقليص الاعتماد
على الدولار. فهل بمقدرتهم تنفيذ
وضرب الدولار في مقتل ومن روسيا
ثلاثمائة وخمسة وستين مواطنا من
بلاروس في قائمة العقوبات وتجميد
مكثفة. وذكرت وسائل اعلام روسية
ان القوات الروسية استهدفت
هل يسمم الحليف اقرب حلفاءه هذا
وذاك صعد الرئيس الاوكراني على
وثلاثين من اصل اربعين صاروخ
كروز اطلقتها روسيا خلال الليل.
ميل البريطانية ان الرئيس
البلاروسي لوكاشينكو تعرض لوعكة
لوكاشينكو وانه بحالة حرجة، فمن
ذا الذي يريد الصاق تهمة بوتين
سيكون اجمل. فما هذه الرسالة
المشفرة؟ وماذا يقصد بوتين؟
روسيا. فكيف سيكون الرد الروسي
بعد هذا؟ وهنا يواصل الاوروبيون
اصول عشرين شركة وستة عشر شخصا
مرتبطين بالقطاع المالي في
موجة المهنئين ليهنئ نظيره رجب
طيب اردوغان باعادة انتخابه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين.
لتشير الصحيفة الى احتمال تسميم
رئيسا لتركيا معبرا عن امله في
تعزيز العلاقات بين البلدين
بث اشاعاتهم اكاذيبهم كما يقول
الكريملين. حيث ذكرت صحيفة ديلي
منظومات باتريوت للدفاع الجوي في
محيط مطار جوليان في كييف وكذلك
للمستشفى، فما الذي جرى؟ بوتين
يوجه رسالة مهمة لاردوغان بينما
تتحول الى حلبة مصارعة بين
الصواريخ الروسية والدفاعات